monsieur bonsoir dans l'actualité de ce
samedi après la turquie le virus de la
grippe aviaire le plus dangereux le h5n1
a été identifié en roumanie cette
nouvelle un site encore davantage
l'europe à se mobiliser contre les
risques d'une propagation dans les
élevages de l'union l'organisation
mondiale de la santé se dit préoccupé
d'autant qu'un deuxième foyer de grippe
aviaire a été détectée hier dans le sud
est de la roumanie
l'abattage de volailles là aussi a
commencé là aussi le village a été placé
en quarantaine laurence de chef josé
boulesteix ni poules les canards ni
aucune bêtes à plumes ne courent
désormais les rues de chez moulia des
jos l'éradication a été totale entre 15
et 17 mille volailles ont été éliminés
il faut maintenant désinfecter pour ne
laisser aucune trace de ce virus de la
grippe aviaire
les habitants ont été indemnisés entre 6
et 9 euros par volaille
comme cet homme qui a vu ses 50 poule
partir je suis content le gouvernement
m'a donné de l'argent et des aliments
pour compenser pour la plupart d'entre
eux leur poule a été destinée à leur
propre consommation
il faudra maintenant faire sans je n'ai
plus mes pommes de terre à cuisiner pour
mes enfants avec de la sauce mais sans
viande à 60 kilomètres de là un deuxième
foyer de grippe aviaire a été détectée
la question non plus de laisser en
poulets vivants
amal yoox les 600 volailles seront
également abattu juste avant la mise en
quarantaine du village nous avons
rencontré les habitants inquiets on a
peur car notre vie est en danger
on ne peut pas rester indifférent car
c'est une maladie mortelle ou l'instant
on a tout arrêté on mange qui tous les
rappeurs les villageois ont tous été
vaccinés contre la grippe humaine
objectif éviter toute rencontre du virus
à vire avec le virus humains pour
empêcher une mutation qui créerait une
nouvelle souche transmissible entre les
hommes mais la roumanie manque déjà de
vaccins et fait appel aux stocks des
pays de l'union européenne